RUBBING THEIR EYES, WHAT'S GOING
ON, YOU WILL REMEMBER THIS FOR
DECADES.
>> IT'S HUGE AND OF COURSE THE
CONDITIONS SHE'S BEEN --
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS ENTERING THE ROOM WITH
GRINER'S WIFE AND THE PRESIDENT.
>> GOOD MORNING, FOLKS.
IT IS A GOOD MORNING.
MOMENTS AGO STANDING TOGETHER I
SPOKE WITH BRITTNEY GRINER.
SHE'S SAFE, SHE'S ON A PLANE, ON
HER WAY HOME AFTER BEING
UNJUSTLY DETAINED IN RUSSIA,
HELD IN INTOLERABLE
CIRCUMSTANCES, BRITNEY WILL SOON
BE BACK IN THE ARMS OF HER LOVED
ONE AND SHE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
THERE ALL ALONG.
WE NEVER STOPPED PUSHING FOR HER
RELEASE.
IT TOOK PAINSTAKING AND INTENSE
NEGOTIATIONS AND I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE HARD WORKING PUBLIC
SERVANTS ACROSS MY
ADMINISTRATION WHO WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO SECURE HER
RELEASE.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE UAE FOR
HELPING US FACILITATE BRITNEY.
Y
THAT'S WHERE SHE LANDED.
THESE PAST FEW MONTHS HAVE BEEN
HELL FOR BRITNEY AND HER ENTIRE
FAMILY.
PEOPLE ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
HAVE LEARNED ABOUT BRITNEY'S
STORY, ADVOCATED FOR HER
RELEASE, STOOD WITH HER
THROUGHOUT THIS TERRIBLE ORDEAL.
I KNOW THAT SUPPORT MEANT A LOT
TO HER FAMILY.
I'M GLAD TO BE ABLE TO SAY
BRITNEY IS IN GOOD SPIRITS.
SHE'S RELIEVED TO FINALLY BE
HEADING HOME AND THE FACT
REMAINS THAT SHE'S LOST MONTHS
OF HER LIFE, EXPERIENCED A
NEEDLESS TRAUMA.
SHE DESERVES SPACE, PRIVACY AND
TIME WITH HER LOVED ONES TO
RECOVER AND HEAL FROM HER TIME
BEING WRONGFULLY DETAINED.
BRITNEY IS AN INCOMPARABLE
ATHLETE, TWO-TIME U.S. OLYMPIC
WINNER FOR THE USA.
SHE SHOWED CHARACTERISTIC GRIT
AND INCREDIBLE INTEGRITY.
HE WROTE TO ME BACK IN JULY.
SHE DIDN'T ASK FOR SPECIAL
TREATMENT, EVEN THOUGH WE'D BEEN
WORKING ON HER RELEASE FROM DAY
ONE.
SHE REQUESTED A SIMPLE, QUOTE,
PLEASE DON'T FORGET ABOUT ME AND
THE OTHER AMERICAN DETAINEES.
PLEASE DO ALL YOU CAN TO BRING
US HOME.
>> WE'VE NEVER FORGOTTEN ABOUT
BRITNEY, WE'VE NEVER FORGOTTEN
ABOUT PAUL WHALEN.
THIS WAS NOT A CHOICE OF WHICH
AMERICAN TO BRING HOME.
WE BROUGHT HOME TREVOR REED.
AND SADLY RUSSIA IS TREATING
PAUL'S CASE DIFFERENT THAN
BRITNEYS AND EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
NOT SECURED PAUL'S RELEASE, WE
WILL NEVER GIVE UP.
WE REMAIN IN CLOSE TOUCH WITH
PAUL'S FAMILY.
MY THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE WITH
THEM TODAY.
THEY HAVE TO HAVE SUCH MIXED
EMOTIONS TODAY.
AND I GUARANTEE YOU.
I URGE RUSSIA TO DO THE SAME TO
ENSURE THAT PAUL'S HEALTH AND
HUMANE TREAT ARE MAINTAINED
UNTIL WE CAN BRING THEM HOME.
I DON'T WANT AMERICAN TO BE
DETAINED ONE EXTRA DAY IF WE CAN
BRING THEM HOME.
DOZENS OF AMERICANS ARE
WRONGFULLY DETAINED, MANY OF
WHOM HAVE BEEN HELD SINCE BEFORE
I TOOK OFFICE.
AND TODAY WE REMEMBER THE OTHER
AMERICANS HELD HOSTAGE AND
WRONGFULLY DETAINED IN RUSSIA OR
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE WORLD.
REUNITING AMERICANS WITH THEIR
LOVED ONES REMAINS A PRIORITY
FOR MY ADMINISTRATION, EVERY
PERSON IN MY ADMINISTRATION
INVOLVED IN THIS.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
TO BRING HOME EVERY AMERICAN WHO
CONTINUES TO ENDURE SUCH AN
INJUSTICE.
AND WE WANT TO PREVENT ANY OTHER
AMERICAN FAMILIES AND I STRONGLY
URGE ALL AMERICANS TO TAKE
CAUTION AND REVIEW TRAVEL
ADVISORIES BEFORE THEY TRAVEL
OVERSEAS, WHICH NOW INCLUDES
WARNING OF BEING WRONGFULLY
DETAINED BY A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT.
MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT.
THIS WORK IS NOT EASY.
NEGOTIATIONS ARE ALWAYS
DIFFICULT.
THERE ARE NEVER ANY GUARANTEES.
BUT IT'S MY JOB AS PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES TO MAKE THE
HARD CALLS AND PROTECT AMERICAN
CITIZENS EVERYWHERE IN THE
WORLD, ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
AND I'M PROUD TODAY WE HAVE MADE
ONE MORE FAMILY WHOLE AGAIN.
SO WELCOME HOME, BRITNEY.
AND NOW I'D LIKE TO INVITE
SHARELLE TO SAY A FEW WORDS.
OF COURSE, SHE'S NOT EXCITED AT
ALL ABOUT THIS.
IT'S ALL YOURS, KIDDO.
CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
>> SO OVER THE LAST NINE MONTHS
YOU ALL HAVE BEEN SO PRIVY TO
ONE OF THE DARKEST MOMENTS OF MY
LIFE AND SO TODAY I'M JUST
STANDING HERE OVERWHELMED WITH
EMOTIONS BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT
EMOTION THAT I HAVE RIGHT NOW IS
JUST SINCERE GRATITUDE FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND HIS ENTIRE
ADMINISTRATION.
HE JUST MENTIONED THIS WORK IS
NOT EASY AND IT HAS NOT BEEN.
THERE AS BEEN SO MANY HANDS
INVOLVED.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
SPECIFICALLY MENTION A FEW, VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS, SECRETARY
BLINKEN, JAKE SULLIVAN, JESS
FROM THE NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL, FLETCHER, SHONE FROM
THE HOSTAGE INVOICE OFFICE, A
SPECIAL THANK YOU TO GOVERNOR
RICHARDSON AND MICKEY, THE
MERCURY PLAYERS, THE WNBPA FOR
YOUR ADVOCACY AND ALSO YOU GUYS
MAY NOT KNOW THIS BUT MY FAMILY
HAS BEEN TREMENDOUSLY SUPPORTED
BY THE WASHINGTON AGENCY.
THEY'VE JUST BEEN AMAZING FOR ME
AND MY FAMILY THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS.
TODAY MY FAMILY IS WHOLE BUT AS
YOU ARE ALL AWARE, MY FAMILY IS
WHOLE.
I WILL SAY THAT B.G. AND I WILL
REMAIN COMMITTED TO THE WORK OF
GETTING EVERY AMERICAN HOME,
INCLUDING PAUL, WHOSE FAMILY IS
IN OUR HEARTS TODAY AS WE
CELEBRATE B.G. BEING HOME.
WE DO UNDERSTAND THERE ARE STILL
PEOPLE OUT HERE WHO ARE ENDURING
WHAT I ENDURED THE LAST NINE
MONTHS OF MISSING TREMENDOUSLY
THEIR LOVED ONE.
SO THANK YOU, EVERYBODY, FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
TODAY IS JUST A HAPPY DAY FOR ME
AND MY FAMILY SO I'M GOING TO
SMILE RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
>> Reporter: MR. PRESIDENT, WHAT
DO YOU SAY TO THE WHALEN FAMILY?
>> WHEN WILL BRITNEY BE BACK IN
THE U.S.?
>> WHAT DID YOU SAY